a major victory for the defenders of our
nation's history and a big rebuke for
those trying to erase America's past Oh
in the wake of those deadly protests in
Charlottesville Virginia in August of
2017 the City Council voted to remove
two Confederate statues but a
Charlottesville Circuit Court judge just
ruled that the statues are war monuments
that are protected under virginia state
law and cannot be moved without
permission or a change in the law
joining me now is Newt Gingrich former
Speaker of the House Fox News
contributor and author of the brand-new
book
collusion out today mr. speaker the
judge here is saying that the people are
making these Confederate statues out to
be something other than what they
actually are just a reminder of our war
history what are your thoughts tonight
well I think that you move towards a
totalitarian state when you start
creating what Orwell described as a
memory hole and you decide which parts
of the past you want to erase and then
you have to lie about who you are you
know it's very funny the left has
decided that robert e lee is
unacceptable and then yet in 1975
senator joe biden voted to give robert e
lee his citizenship back something he'd
lost in a civil war so this remarkable
changes I think that the whole effort on
the left to erase American history is
wrong
I think people ought to stand up for it
you're not standing up for the values of
those people you're standing up for the
fact that they were a significant part
of American history they deserve to be
studied as part of American history and
I think that in fact studying the role
of slavery and the and the Civil War
helps you better understand America well
it understands our scars our lessons the
great struggle for independence and
freedom for all people and it's it's
bizarre have you been to New Orleans and
where Lee Circle is Newt that huge
pedestal yes where they just removed
Mitch Landrieu just had that remove
moved in the middle of the night I don't
think anyone even knows where that went
I don't know how much money it's worth
but now it's just a it's just a stark
reminder of of this Taliban esque
approach to American history not
endorsing you no one's endorsing slavery
but I think they're just saying okay
this is what we came from and I think we
should build new new monuments new
memorials to expand the conversation
it's it's very it's very odd but I want
to move on to the dirty politics going
on in Washington Newt because president
Trump's refusal now to cooperate with
these endless Democrat subpoenas it's
now intensifying the Democrats push for
impeachment let's watch I think the
president has escalated the conflict
with Congress well finally they got
around to invoking executive privilege
over at the White House which I think
they should have invoked a long time ago
and Owen McGann was in the in the White
House counsel's office but what's your
advice to the president in this in this
pitched battle
well I start with the obvious reality a
Republican Senate is not going to
convict the president of anything it's
not going to happen
therefore the Democrats and House can
jump up and down they can scream they
can hold their breath until they turn
purple
it doesn't matter they're not going to
have any ability to get anything done in
terms of impeachment so if I recommend
the president is these people have
proven that they have no interest in the
truth they have no interest in the facts
and if you give in they'll just demand
more and so I think he's very wise to
draw a firm line in the ground and say
no we're not going to cooperate as I
also think Attorney General Barr is very
wise to not agree to allow lawyers who
are on the staff to ask questions
there's a changes totally the
relationship and frankly allows purely
professional politicians who are trained
lawyers to sit in there and spend weeks
preparing ways to try to track them well
we'll do fine against members of
Congress but nobody is going to win
against the whole
series of very very well trained staff
lawyers and do very well it's just it's
preposterous this is only being done for
politics sake
so as you mentioned some bars bar shows
up tomorrow there's going to be two days
of testimony about you know 24 hours
after this reported Muller letter
dropped but minoo that bar bar says he's
not going to show up for the second
session if Democrats don't back down on
their demand for like an extra hour of
questioning by lawmakers in committee
attorneys so Jerry Nadler is saying well
bar as in the Attorney General just not
going to have a choice new to the
Attorney General to tell the committee
how to conduct this business or we will
decide what the most effective way of
asking questions are and we that's what
our decision is if he doesn't show up on
Thursday we'll have to go to subpoenas
well I guess bring it we'll see you in
court
yeah look uh again the subpoena normally
is unenforceable
you can't they're not kind of very
effective in subpoenaing the Attorney
General and they end up looking a little
the more they do this the tired of the
country is going to get and in that
sense I think Trump has a shrewd
understanding that if he can get the
Democrats into publicly being so focused
on this kind of game that the country
will begin to be very tired of the
Democrats as people who aren't trying to
help solve America's problems and Newt I
have to ask you about the timing of this
leak tonight of the Muller letter to bar
which is being completely
mischaracterized people are frothing at
the mouth at the other networks and
they're like oh Mullen was telling him
he's get mischaracterizing the report
it's so patently ridiculous on its face
like Bill Barr would totally
misrepresent the report that was about
to be released it's crazy but what do
you make of this timing of the leak well
I assume somebody wanted to leak it to
maximize the embarrassment to bar and to
set up the questions for the hearings in
the next two days you know look the deep
state in Washington has played these
games for the whole history of the
country
this is not something new both Jefferson
and Hamilton used to subsidize
newspapers to attack each other while
they were both serving the president
President Washington's cabinet so we've
had a long history of this stuff but I
think again it's one of those places
where after all the noise you just shrug
your shoulders and say so what
Moeller had every opportunity to come
out the day that Barr released his
letter Mullica at any point have decided
he wanted to refute it and as I
understand the actual key sentences the
distortion is by the news media
right the source is not by bar he said I
don't disagree with the outcome of your
of your synopsis but it was the way the
media was pounding pounding pounding
more like thinking about this stuff the
media that Muller is complaining about
are the people who are now using
Muller's complaint to try to further
distort what's going on I mean you
couldn't make this up I Newt I want to
congratulate you your new book just out
today called collusion it's a novel
everybody has to read it I think that
point is not about Muller
it's not about Muller but it's it's so
typical Gingrich to just time it
perfectly news okay Congrats no we're
all we're all reading it and I tweeted
about it today and we're gonna be on the
podcast so thank you so much thank you